>> Bret: PRESIDENT TRUMP ON
THE SOUTH LAWN TELLING 5:00 P.M.
SATURDAY, LET’S LISTEN IN.
>> HAD A GOOD CONFERENCE.
I’VE TALKED TO MANY PEOPLE, MANY
PEOPLE.
>> WHY HAVEN’T YOU SAID ANYTHING
ABOUT THE U.S. HITTING 200 200,0
DEATHS?
>> OVERHEAD, ANYBODY ELSE?
>> A NEW MODEL SHOWS 200,000
DEATHS OF THE VIRUS PAID WHAT
YOU WANT TO SAY TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE?
>> I THINK IT’S A SHAME.
I THINK IF WE DIDN’T DO IT
PROPERLY AND DIDN’T DO IT RIGHT,
YOU’D HAVE TWO AND A HALF
MILLION DEATHS IF YOU TAKE A
LOOK AT ALTERNATIVES, YOU COULD
HAVE TWO AND A HALF MILLION
DEATHS OR SOMETHING THEREABOUTS.
HE COULD HAVE A NUMBER THAT
WOULD BE MORE.
WITH ALL OF THAT BEING SAID, WE
SHOULDN’T HAVE HAD ANYBODY AND
YOU SAW MY UNITED NATIONS
SPEECH, CHINA SHOULD HAVE
STOPPED IT AT THEIR BORDER.
THEY SHOULD’VE NEVER LET THE
SPREAD ALL OVER THE WORLD, AND
IT’S A TERRIBLE THING, BUT HAVE
WE NOT CLOSE OUR COUNTRY DOWN
AND REOPENED AND NOW DOING WELL
AND REOPENING, THE STOCK MARKET
IS UP, ALL O OF THOSE THINGS BUT
THINK IT’S A HORRIBLE THING.
THREE AND A HALF OR 3 MILLION
BUT IT’S A HORRIBLE THING,
SHOULD HAVE NEVER HAPPENED.
IN CHINA LET THIS HAPPEN, JUST
REMEMBER THAT.
I KNOW THIS, THE ORIGINAL
NUMBERS WERE AROUND 200,000 IF
YOU DO IT RIGHT IF YOU DID A
GOOD JOB AND THE PUBLIC WORKED
ALONG IT IF YOU DIDN’T DO IT
RIGHT, YOU’D BE AT TWO AND A
HALF MILLION, THOSE WERE THE
NUMBERS BUT THAT SHOULD’VE NEVER
HAPPENED, SHOULD HAVE NEVER COME
OUT OF CHINA, SHOULD HAVE NEVER
LET IT HAPPEN.
I DON’T WANT TO TALK ABOUT WHO I
AM MEETING WITH I’VE SPOKEN TO
MANY AND WE ARE GETTING CLOSE TO
A DECISION, GOING TO BE DOING IT
ON SATURDAY, MEETING ON
SATURDAY, A LOT OF PAPERWORK TO
DO AND I THINK IT’S GOING TO GO
VERY QUICKLY.
I DON’T THINK SO.
WE NEED NINE JUSTICES.
YOU NEED THAT.
WITH THE UNSOLICITED MILLIONS OF
BALLOTS THAT THEY ARE SENDING,
IT’S A SCAM, IT’S A HOAX,
EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT AND THE
DEMOCRATS KNOW IT BETTER THAN
ANYBODY ELSE, SO YOU’RE GOING TO
NEED NINE JUSTICES UP THERE.
IT’S GOING TO BE VERY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE WHAT THEY’RE DOING IS A
HOAX WITH THE BALLOTS.
THEY ARE SENDING OUT TENS OF
MILLIONS OF BALLOTS UNSOLICITED,
NOT WHERE THEY’RE BEING ASKED,
BUT UNSOLICITED.
AND THAT’S A HOAX.
AND YOU’RE GOING TO NEED TO HAVE
A NINE JUSTICES SO DOING IT
BEFORE THE ELECTION WOULD BE A
VERY GOOD THING BECAUSE YOU’RE
GOING TO PROBABLY SEE IT BECAUSE
WHAT THEY ARE DOING IS TRYING TO
SELL CONFUSION AND EVERYTHING
ELSE AND WHEN THEY TALK ABOUT
RUSSIA, CHINA, AND ALL THESE
OTHERS, PAPER BALLOTS ARE VERY
SIMPLE WHETHER THEY COUNTERFEIT
THEM, FORGE THEM, DO WHATEVER
YOU WANT.
IT’S A VERY SERIOUS PROBLEM, AND
THE DEMOCRATS KNOW WHAT THEY’RE
DOING IS WRONG AND ALL THEY WANT
TO DO IS GO FORWARD WITH IT SO I
THINK YOU ARE GOING TO NEED THE
JUSTICES.
ALSO, I HAVE A CONSTITUTIONAL
OBLIGATION TO PUT IN NINE
JUSTICES, SO I THINK YOU’RE
GOING TO BE VERY IMPRESSED WHEN
YOU SEE ALL OF THEM.
THEY’RE ALL GREAT.
THESE ARE ALL VERY TALENTED